donat tokio oder maßmann schwanz ist
leider nicht vorhanden
hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video mache heute den ultimativen test
mit euch wir finden heute heraus ob ich
babys beauty palace gut kenne ich bin
heißt es das quiz beinhaltet zwölf
fragen jetzt wurde erstellt von amelia
entwickelt am ersten 12 2016
hunderttausend mal aufgerufen die
überbewertung des tatsächlich zu
wünschen übrig aber ich würd sagen frage
wie heißt die eigene marke oder hat die
mal kleiner als ob ich jetzt weiß dass
mich leute ich glaube das ist wirklich
sehr sehr einfache einstiegsfrage jeder
bei dreck die antwort nein sie hat
natürlich keine eigene marke wir kennen
natürlich alle die mit beauty pellets
die ist nicht so auf das geld aus
wann hat sie ihr erstes video
hochgeladen am zweiten 12 2012 am
fünften dritten 2012 oder am 13 august
2012 dicker ich glaube die weiß das
datum selbst nicht mal ich habe
überhaupt kein plan ich will auch nicht
reinschauen auf den kanal deswegen eene
meene mit rappelt in der kiste ene mene
meck ich den hier was ist bewies
lieblingstier ein igel ein elefant oder
ein pferd max ich würde mal sagen igel
weil igel wenn süß welche süßigkeit lied
baby donath tokio oder maschinell
schwarzen leider nicht vorhanden
ich habe schon wieder keine ahnung
eigentlich ist das typische promis und
erfolg auf abgehen diesem bild bei
instagram schoki etwas ist schokolade
marshmallows doch einfach falsch
geschrieben ich will trotzdem sagen
marshmallows weiß geschrieben jetzt
vielleicht kann mir das auch nicht
richtig schreiben übrigens kein front an
an be oder so das ist ja alles nur humor
na also größtenteils wie heißt wie in
echt baby ist ja ein spitzname bianca
hey baby it's nachhaltiger danke für
diesen zweck janka heinicke bin ja
golfer oder bi banja beauty
ja leute das wird wieder so eine sache
nicht wirklich wie dunklen kürzer
schneller beiden diebinnen job youtube
wie sonst kommt man auf den namen wie
youtube etwas wie meine dass youtube
findet sind dabei komme dem palast ich
möchte ja wie heißen die fans vom baby
baby nature bibi vips oder biene als ich
würde sagen baby bekommen auch schon zum
siebten frage wer mag bibi als sänger
sängerinnen charlie chaplin lena gomez
justin bieber rihanna ich würde dann mit
raps weil das der einzige von denen den
ich nicht kenne die achte frage die
haarfarben von babyalter die haarfarben
die hat doch jeden tag an rare 2012 bis
2016 okay war sie in der ganzen zeit war
sie blond grün lila braun blond roter
rainbow mermaid braut oder blond braun
rot klasse platz zur definitiven ladet
sie im dann ladet wie immer neue videos
hoch montags und freitags nach lust und
laune wenn sie lust hat selten ich würde
mal sagen welten leute drittletzte frage
magst du babyalter warum solche fragen
geht so bisschen okay ich habe sie ja
ich würde mal sagen wir zählen wieder
durch eine mine mit rappelt in der kiste
ich hatte sid wie hat die auf musical
mit ihrem freund julian keine ahnung
ehrlich gesagt haben sie haben zusammen
dann keine ahnung
letzte frage wie hat dir das pferd
gefallen sehr gut war okay was anderes
als was die person die so erstellte sagt
christo weniger punkte scheiße leute
sind sehr gespannt auf die auswertung
liefert etwa vor du bist nicht wirklich
ein teenager schaut manchmal videos
kommentiert und leicht nicht folgt ihnen
auch nirgendwo kennt sie nur von anderen
wir haben ein von zwölf aufgaben
wir haben eine aufgabe richtig das war
meine damen und herren endlich gefallen
hat das gerne mal ein like da mag es
nicht in der beschreibung verlegen hier
vorne findet ihr in smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr darauf könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren findet auch meinen job
eingeblendet und hier unten ist ein
anderes video und ich bin gerade wenn
ich das video steht in wien weil ich
dort morgen auf dem fantreffen bin seit
wochen kommt